either Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about conjugations and
declensions I talk here about language
learning if these videos interest you
please subscribe and you probably know
that I'm a co-founder of link and if you
want to work on your languages come on
over and visit us at link but one of my
experiences in language learning early
on was that the deliberate study of
declension tables didn't work for me
first of all for those who don't know
conjugations are the list of different
verb endings that change depending on
person a number and of course tense and
so forth so the verbs in many languages
change quite a bit depending on those
conditions declensions that's how the
nouns and adjectives change and so in
many languages you have to be able to or
ideally you're able to use the correct
form the correct ending for these verbs
and nouns and adjectives many people
find that very difficult so do i the
best way to get good at it in my opinion
is not to get hung up on trying to
memorize them my German learning was
severely I would say [ __ ] by my
effort to try to ace these tables it's
just so different from what we're used
to in our own language in many cases
like if you're coming from English that
in my experience no amount of studying
reviewing memorizing enabled me to learn
these endings however when I decided not
to try to ace the endings but rather to
learn a bunch of words to see that I to
try to understand the language then I
started doing much better because I was
no longer there is no longer this
obstacle that I have to a STIs endings
before I can proceed in the language I
just proceeded in the language and I
always use this proof that you know the
deliberate study of the endings doesn't
help a lot and and the example I use is
is in English where the only ending that
changes is the third person singular he
goes it goes it walks it says and yet
the number of learners who speak English
very well and who have been added for 10
years or longer and even native speakers
who use you know it goes especially if
the noun or the subject is separated a
little bit from the verb the S ending
disappears and that's in something as
simple as the rules of of conjugation in
English so the likelihood to me that you
can ace it you can however and and
twittered a bit on this and there it got
the usual reaction oh no I have to study
the tables otherwise and so forth I just
don't believe it I think very often we
think that we're learning something
because we're reviewing tables or were
you know reading the dictionary but in
my experience and I think for a lot of
people it doesn't really stick and it is
an obstacle it is a something that
intimidates people eventually you get
used to it because you start to notice
certain expressions for example in
Russian the instrumental plural was the
first one that clicked in because you
heard so often as through the army you
know whatever that the army which
implied that it was with somebody plural
tense that was one of the first that
that came in French you get used to fact
he just started naturally after a while
through enough exposure you know you're
Bosco say like that's a positive
statement I think that it is but you
know pause Parker SAS soir so it becomes
subjunctive so has a different ending
again
so those kinds of rules so so this whole
idea of the deliberate study of
something is no guarantee you're gonna
learn it now I'm not suggesting that you
shouldn't review these rules because
very often you may not getting back to
my belief that noticing is the beginning
of learning in language learning so we
have to start noticing noticing things
and at first you don't notice and so to
that extent reviewing the grammar going
over the rules reviewing it again
many times because the first time you
forget most of what you look at nothing
wrong with reviewing it from time to
time but studying it or reviewing it
with the intent oh you're gonna ace it
master it in my experience has not been
successful so that's just a little more
background to the tweet that I put out
the other day about to learn
conjugations and declensions don't study
them just listen and read and get used
to them bye for now
you